what of the changes that we introduced
on the art side coming to Ghost Recon
phantoms is having a phantom side of the
ghost for visual artist source we need
to start with an idea we flesh it out by
using concept part basically concept
part will help us to channel the idea
the color to the management let everyone
alert them what we are doing what will
the Emperor that looks like talking
about the maps it's coming from the
concept art and the direction from the
director process model and then from
there we going to translate this idea is
sufficient into the kims the cosecant
anthems and what I'm doing a work
closely with the technical artists we
set up the tools we iterate the tools to
make the artists life make it easier
it's also when we start from level
design it's all about making something
fun and where the artist comes in it's
all about making the level design
invisible to the player in to feel like
it's a real place it's not designed by
someone I'm just here and trying to
capture a point we have one new map for
Ghost Recon phantom it's called dr.
Wilson's article its spiral map its
display heart and then the location is
based on Taiwan this pre interesting was
an existing map we are try to relight it
on our new lighting system in this
caustic on pendants we try to push all
of the new technology into existing map
all of the new like things happen in all
of the other maps instead of the just a
new map so i can wait to see what your
guys direction about the new maps the
new lighting should be super excited one
of the major challenges that the art
team is face would be the
a constant improvement of our pipelines
as once we start shipping more and more
acts and hats to run into this
difficulty of creating something that's
fresh but also within the brand we are
not a fantasy or cartoni game and we're
fairly hard for military shooter and
need to find that balance between
creating something that's appealing and
something that's still good evil and
something that fits a Tom Clancy brat I
create character animations I make our
characters move reload weapons jump over
things take cover